[Musique]
à quelques jours du réveillon
voici une succursale de l'atelier du
père noël où s'agitent de petites mains
qui créent de toutes pièces
les tenues qui vont sublimer les femmes
pour ces fêtes de fin d'année c'est ici
que la styliste sylviane gaudy a relancé
son activité après quatre ans d'arrêt
on a pas que les fêtes lui 31 et de noël
donc on a aussi les chanter noël donc
les dames cherche aussi des tenues elles
veulent être belles
pour paul et chanté noël donc aussi on a
donc du coup je propose aussi du jean
aussi les cotonnades et pour les fêtes
de la soie la dentelle enfin on utilise
un peu tôt car la marque de fabrique de
sylviane gaudy c'est justement le
mélange de matières et pour cette fin
d'année les couleurs et les formes
vaporeuse sont à l'honneur sur une année
d'activité la période de novembre à
décembre
le représentant entre 40 à 50% du
chiffre d'affaires c'est la période où
les femmes n'hésitent pas à mettre le
prix pour être original effectivement là
le chiffre d'affaires est un petit peu
plus important donc par rapport aux 15
mois d'un précédent qui va la rentrée la
personne qui achète enfin il ya les
impôts il ya tout en fait les dames ne
peuvent pas acheter à la rentrée tout ça
donc le 31 à elle se rattrape dans les
tissus sont achetés avant donc bon les
achats sont faits avant et après il faut
trouver
la bonne tenue dans la bonne matière
tout ça donc il faut à peu près un mois
et demi et pour avoir une bonne
collection il faut avoir une production
de 60 à 80 pièces quand même un travail
colossal et très peu de sommeil pour ne
rater aucune occasion d'écouler sa
collection
les ventes se font en participant à des
événements privés des salons encore à
son showroom au total sur cette période
un minimum de cinq à six événements
catlin qui défilent pour la styliste
depuis plus de dix ans c'est quelque
chose on peut s'en rend compte de la
masse de travail que sa demande les gens
troqué styliste et aussi de pouvoir
proposer de nouvelles choses qu'on ne
voit pas et surtout des pièces uniques
j'imagine que c'est un énorme travail et
je suis content d'être à ses côtés pour
justement mettre en valeur ce travail
lors des défilés avec elle le marathon
de noël de la styliste sieleghem gaudi
se poursuit ce samedi par un nouveau
défilé au lamentin
[Musique]